It's never easy to see a child experiencing pain, sadness, even loss, but it's those experiences that can help them learn how to be emotionally healthy adults if they have the right tools. In this episode, we speak with one psychologist about how to talk to children about loss, as well as the importance of mindfulness and other self-regulation techniques as they attempt to manage stress and other day-to-day challenges. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is speaking of psychology. Bonnie Zucker is a licensed clinical psychologist. She has a private practice in Rockville, Maryland, where she works with young children, teens, and their families. She can often be found out in her community at schools and talking with parents about how to help children manage stress and everyday challenges.
看到孩子经历痛苦、悲伤甚至失去亲人，从来都不是件容易的事，但正是这些经历，如果他们拥有正确的工具，可以帮助他们学会如何成为情绪健康的成年人。在本期节目中，我们与一位心理学家探讨了如何与儿童谈论失去，以及正念和其他自我调节技术在他们试图应对压力和日常挑战时的重要性。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是心理学访谈。邦妮·祖克是一位持证临床心理学家。她在马里兰州罗克维尔拥有自己的私人诊所，在那里她与幼儿、青少年及其家庭合作。人们经常可以在她所在社区的学校里看到她，并与家长讨论如何帮助孩子管理压力和日常挑战。
She is the author of several books, including anxiety-free kids, and take control of OCD, the ultimate guide for kids with OCD. Her latest book is called Something Very Sad Happened, a Toddler's Guide to Understanding Death, published by Imagination Press. Welcome, Dr. Zucker. Thank you so much for having me. I want to start with your latest book because I think this is something many parents struggle with, talking with your kids about death at any age really, but particularly very young
她是几本书的作者，包括《无焦虑儿童》和《掌控强迫症：强迫症儿童终极指南》。她的最新一本书名为《发生了一件非常伤心的事：幼儿理解死亡指南》，由Imagination Press出版。欢迎您，祖克博士。非常感谢邀请我。我想从你的最新一本书开始，因为我认为这是许多家长都在纠结的事情，无论在什么年龄段，真正地和孩子谈论死亡，尤其是非常小的
children. What made you want to write this book and what is it about? Thank you. So actually, I was personally motivated, unlike my other books, which my clinical experience, developed the concepts. For this, about six years ago, my mother passed away, and my son, who is now eight, was two at the time. And my go-to was to find a book for him. And I went to the bookstore. I could not find a book written on death for two- and three-year-olds. They had a really good one called, I Miss You. That was for ages four and up, which I did buy and simplified
儿童。是什么让你想写这本书，它讲的是什么？谢谢。其实，我是出于个人动机，这与我其他通过临床经验发展出概念的书籍不同。大约六年前，我的母亲去世了，当时我的儿子八岁，两岁。我的首选是为他找一本书。我去了书店。我找不到一本为两三岁孩子写关于死亡的书。他们有一本很好的书叫《我思念你》。那是为四岁及以上的孩子准备的，我确实买了并简化了
for him. But I remember at the time, in the midst of my grief, thinking, I have got to write a book for kids at this age because at two and three parents are in the habit of reading every night to their kids and usually by the age of two or three kids can identify with books it's a great way of teaching them something and also for grief it allows them to go back and rehear over and over the things that are important for them to learn about it similarly the developmental understanding for a two and three year old it's very different than someone who's four or five or older I wrote it in a language that was designed for the developmental understanding of a two and three-year-old child. So what happens in the book?
给他听。但我记得当时，在悲伤中，我想：我必须为这个年龄段的孩子写一本书，因为在两三岁的时候，父母已经习惯了每晚给孩子读书，通常到两三岁时，孩子可以通过书本产生共鸣，这是教导他们某些东西的好方法，对于悲伤来说，它也允许他们回去一遍又一遍地重听那些对他们了解它很重要的事。同样地，两三岁孩子的发育理解力与四五岁或更大的人非常不同，我用专为两三岁儿童发育理解力设计的语言写了这本书。那么书里发生了什么？
So what happens in the book? It's actually the illustrator made this book. I mean, people, I show them the book and they say, wow, this looks amazing. I said, I know, doesn't it? And really, I'm not speaking of my work. I'm speaking of the illustrations, which just expressed the story so beautifully. they're really, she was very sensitive in her approach, even the expressions of the mother and the little boy in the book. So what happens is the mom and the child who, again, looks like a three-year-old
那么书里发生了什么？实际上是插画家创作了这本书。我的意思是，人们，我给他们看这本书，他们说，哇，这看起来太棒了。我说，我知道，不是吗？真的，我不是在说我的工作。我说的是插图，它们把故事表达得如此优美。它们真的，她在处理方式上非常敏感，甚至连书中母亲和小男孩的表情也是如此。所以发生的事情是，妈妈和那个再次看起来像三岁的孩子
boy, are sitting down and the mother explains that something very sad has happened, grandma died. And I wrote the book with the words grandma and the pronouns, she and her. her coded and read so that the read you said the right exactly so it can be changed so the reader who should prepare in advance to read this book to the child by reading it once themselves can be queued to change it let's say it's a father who died or an uncle that it could be switched to something very sad happened uncle so-and-so died he and then they would be able to personalize it so it so it makes sense for the child and so the boy and the mom go through sort of these pages of emotions, feeling sad.
男孩坐下来，母亲解释说发生了一件非常伤心的事情，奶奶去世了。我写这本书时，把“奶奶”这个词和代词“她”和“她的”用红色编码，以便读者——你刚才说得对，完全可以改变，这样预先准备好给孩子读这本书的读者可以通过自己读一遍来得到提示，比如可以把它们改掉，假设是一个死去的父亲或叔叔，就可以换成“发生了一件非常伤心的事情，某某叔叔死了，他……”然后他们就能将其个性化，以便对孩子来说说得通。所以男孩和妈妈经历了这些情绪的页面，感到悲伤。
You might see your mom feel sad. You might feel angry. You might see your mom feel angry. And what was amazing about the illustrations is it actually goes from lighter-toned colors to more vibrant colors as the book progresses. And then toward the end of the book, it talks about how we can remember grandma.
你可能会看到你的妈妈感到难过。你可能会感到生气。你可能会看到你的妈妈感到生气。这些插图最神奇的地方在于，随着图书的进展，它实际上从色调较浅的颜色过渡到更具活力的颜色。然后在书的结尾，它谈到了我们如何能记住奶奶。
We can look at pictures. We can hear, talk about her, listen to stories about her. And then the very last line of the book is love cannot die. You know, love never dies. And so that's, and it's a very vibrant, colorful page, the last couple of, you know, last two pages. I know that you work with families and also you have children yourself, so you have your
我们可以看照片。我们可以听到、谈论她，听关于她的故事。然后这本书的最后一句话是爱不会死。你知道，爱永不消逝。这就是，这是一个非常充满活力、色彩斑斓的页面，最后几页，你知道，最后两页。我知道你和家庭一起工作，而且你自己也有孩子，所以你有
personal experiences. But as a therapist, as a psychologist, you know, I'm sure parents are always worried about saying the wrong thing, you know, definitely want to, or further confusing the child. Is there anything that people or adults should not say to children when they're dealing with death? That's a great question. And I do think that while we want to just be as authentic as possible in our parenting, there are times when you have to limit what you say.
个人经历。但是作为一名治疗师，作为一名心理学家，你知道，我确信父母总是担心说错话，你知道，肯定想，或者进一步混淆孩子。当面对死亡时，人们或成年人不应该对孩子说什么吗？这是一个很好的问题。我确实认为，虽然我们希望在育儿过程中尽可能保持真实，但有时你必须限制你说的话。
And mostly when it comes to conversations about death, I think for a young child, you have to be very clear and planned about what you want to say. You want to avoid terms like sleep or long sleep. You don't want to say when someone dies, it's like they're sleeping because it's not like they're sleeping. They're not going to wake up. And for the child at this age, they don't understand so much the irreversibility of death. So we want to be very clear in that message. And we also don't want to make them anxious about sleep.
主要是当谈到关于死亡的对话时，我认为对于一个幼儿来说，你必须对你想说的话非常清晰和有计划。你要避免使用诸如睡眠或长时间睡眠之类的词。当有人死去时，你不能说这就像他们在睡觉，因为这不像睡觉。他们不会醒来。对于这个年龄的孩子来说，他们不太理解死亡的不可逆转性。所以我们希望在这个信息中非常明确。而且我们也不想让他们对睡眠感到焦虑。
Because that's something. Right. I don't want to go to sleep if it's going to be like death. And also, we really want to be sensitive to not telling them what to feel. feel. So you don't want to say things like, you know, you can feel happy now because the person is no longer in pain. That's not going to make sense to them. That's going to further confuse them, particularly when they're watching people go through, their family members go through a loss and they're sad a lot. And also if it's a suicide or a homicide, I really recommend in those
因为那是某种。对。如果这就像死亡一样，我不想去睡觉。而且，我们真的要对不告诉他们去感受什么保持敏感。所以你不想说这样的话，你知道，你现在可以感到高兴，因为这个人不再痛苦了。这讲不通。这只会让他们更加困惑，特别是当他们看着人们经历痛苦时，他们的家庭成员经历了失去而他们经常悲伤。而且如果是自杀或他杀，我真的建议在那些
times to not be authentic and not say so-and-so killed themselves or so-and-so was killed. I think you have to essentially lie to the child. Because it's too complex, they can't understand it. And I think you just have to say things that basically mislead the understanding of how they died. And then when the child is older, you can be more honest with them. And then one final point is really, I do think it's important to not encourage the child to move on too much or to tell them that we don't want to talk about this anymore.
时候不要表现真实，不要说某某人自杀或某某人被杀。我认为你基本上必须对孩子撒谎。因为这太复杂了，他们无法理解。我认为你只需说一些基本上会误导他们如何死去理解的话。然后当孩子大一点时，你可以对他们更诚实。最后一点是，我确实认为不要鼓励孩子太多地向前看或者告诉他们我们不想再谈论这件事是很重要的。
As shocking as that might sound to say to a child, I've actually had this. happened a couple of times. One was with a foster child I was working with whose biological mom had died and then he was adopted by the foster family and they cued him, this is your family now. We don't need to talk about, you know, your birth family. Yet in the therapy room with me, who is really not ready to move on. And so I think we just have to trust kids. They do a really good job when it comes to being authentic to their feelings and navigating their emotions. And we want to take their lead and figure out what they bring to the table in terms of their emotions and have sort of fundamental respect for their process. I want to switch gears a little bit and talk a little
尽管对孩子说这话听起来可能令人震惊，但我实际上遇到过这种情况。有好几次。其中一次是我合作过的一个寄养儿童，他的亲生母亲去世了，后来他被寄养家庭收养，他们暗示他，这是你的家人。我们不需要谈论，你知道，你的亲生家庭。然而在治疗室里和我在一起，他真的还没准备好向前看。所以我想我们只需要信任孩子。当涉及到对他们的情感保持真实和驾驭自己的情绪时，他们做得非常好。我们希望顺从他们的引导，弄清楚他们在情感方面带给我们什么，并对他们的过程有根本的尊重。我想稍微改变一下话题，谈谈
bit about the mind-body connection with kids. You see a lot of schools now are focusing on this. For example, my own daughter's kindergarten classroom. They've started incorporating mindfulness practices in the classroom, which I find really interesting and, you know, that she finds interesting as well. How do these types of programs and practices work and what does the research tell us about the benefits. That's a great question, and I'm thrilled that your daughter's kindergarten class is doing this, because I find overall that when it happens in the school, it starts happening at home too, because kids come home and they want to do these kinds of practices. So we know there's a very strong mind-body connection, and we know, and the research, there's really good research done
关于儿童的心身连接。你看到现在很多学校都在关注这一点。例如，我女儿自己的幼儿园教室。他们已经开始在课堂上纳入正念练习，我觉得这真的很有趣，而且，你知道，她也觉得有趣。这些类型的计划和实践是如何运作的，研究告诉我们关于好处的什么。这是一个很好的问题，我很高兴你女儿的幼儿园班级在这样做，因为我发现总的来说，当它发生在学校里时，它也开始在家发生，因为孩子们回家后想做这种练习。所以我们知道存在非常强大的心身联系，而且我们知道，在研究中，有非常好的研究是由
by Herbert Benson, who's one of the first to really write about anxiety in a popular way. And he wrote this book a couple years back called Relaxation Revolution, which summarizes his findings through studies on mind-body practices. And by the way, those mind-body practices include things like meditation and yoga and, you know, listening to certain chants and music. And what they found, and they did this really amazing study with over 2,000 genes that they looked at in these experienced mind-body practitioners. And when you, when you, when you, when you, think about genes, you think about are you genetically predisposed to something. So I may have a genetic predisposition to something like lung cancer, but that gene never gets switched on if I don't smoke,
赫伯特·本森完成的，他是最早以通俗方式真正撰写关于焦虑文章的人之一。几年前，他写了一本名为《放松革命》的书，总结了他通过对心身练习研究的发现。顺便说一句，这些心身练习包括冥想、瑜伽、听某些吟诵和音乐等。他们发现，他们对这些经验丰富的心身实践者身上观察到的2000多条基因进行了非常惊人的研究。当你想到基因时，你会想到你是否对某事有基因易感性。所以我可能对肺癌之类的东西有基因易感性，但如果我不吸烟，那个基因就永远不会被开启
if I exercise, if I eat well. And so a gene doesn't mean you will have it. Instead, you want to look at the conditions that turn a gene on or don't turn the switch on. So they found that these genes in these mind-body practitioners, especially ones associated with cardiac problems and oxidative stress, were not expressed in the same way as in the genes of the inexperienced practitioners. So this is sort of remarkable evidence that shows that when you do things like mindfulness and relaxation training and yoga, that you are setting your body up to not express certain genes that could cause a lot of illness and disease in people. And the idea of kids learning this, especially when we add in the different environment that kids these days are growing up in with technology.
如果我锻炼，如果我吃得好。所以有基因并不意味着你就会得病。相反，你要看那些开启基因或不开启开关的条件。因此，他们发现这些心身实践者体内的这些基因，尤其是那些与心脏问题和氧化应激相关的基因，其表达方式与经验不足的实践者体内的基因不同。所以这是一个非凡的证据，表明当你做诸如正念、放松训练和瑜伽之类的事情时，你是在让你的身体不去表达某些可能在人们身上引起大量疾病的基因。孩子们学习这个的概念，特别是当我们加入孩子们如今在技术环境下成长的不同环境时。
While we love our phones and some of us love them more than others, we really are creating an entirely different experience for kids these days. And in fact, some people even say that when kids are using phones a lot and they're switching between topics quickly, that it could encourage them inattentive behavior. And the idea of having this mindfulness to rely on to clear your mind, to enter into a thoughtless state, and to really align your mind and body in a very positive way, I would view it as preventative medicine. How do you know if your child or children would benefit from relaxation and self-regulation techniques? I mean, argument can be made that all children should be going through this. Of course, right? But how do you go about finding the best program? Yes, that's an excellent point.
虽然我们喜欢手机，我们有些人比其他人更喜欢，但我们确实在为现在的孩子们创造一种完全不同的体验。事实上，有些人甚至说，当孩子们经常使用手机并在不同的话题之间快速切换时，可能会促使他们产生注意力不集中的行为。依靠这种正念来净化心灵、进入无思状态并以非常积极的方式真正将心身保持一致的概念，我认为这是一种预防医学。你怎么知道你的孩子是否会从放松和自我调节技术中受益？我的意思是，可以争辩说所有的孩子都应该经历这个。当然，对吧？但你如何去寻找最好的程序呢？是的，这是一个极好的观点。
My goal is for kids to be working on this at home with their families. And I find in my work with families that parents are just as happy to be doing it as kids are. And I essentially think all kids need to learn how to do calm breathing and one nostril breathing, which is where you close one nostril and you close your mouth and you breathe in very slowly in and out through the other nostril. Usually you breathe in for seven and out for nine, something like that. And you do it for several minutes until you get really relaxed. but there are all these apps now where parents can help their children learn how to relax. For example, com, com, which is an app, it's calm.com, C-A-L-M.
我的目标是让孩子们在家里和家人一起做这件事。我在与家庭合作时发现，父母和孩子一样乐于去做。我基本上认为所有的孩子都需要学习如何做平静呼吸和单鼻孔呼吸，也就是你闭上一个鼻孔，闭上嘴巴，通过另一个鼻孔非常缓慢地吸气和呼气。通常你吸气七秒，呼气九秒，诸如此类。你做几分钟，直到你真正放松下来。但现在有所有这些应用程序，父母可以帮助孩子学习如何放松。例如，com，com，这是一个应用程序，它是calm.com，C-A-L-M。
They have an amazing bedtime stories part of the app, which part of the app is free and part of it you have to pay for. And the bedtime stories, unfortunately, it's something you have to pay for. But I've had kids who've had a lot of trouble relaxing before bed, and they listen to these stories. there's one where the man's voice is like this and I mean you almost want to fall asleep the second he starts talking and and of course that's one way to use it another way is not at bedtime but for them to really learn how to relax and how to decompress and what I suggest is getting on you know getting on your phone and looking at the different ones I have a list in my head that I often recommend insight timer is a really good one.
他们有一个应用程序中非常棒的睡前故事部分，应用程序的一部分是免费的，一部分你必须付费。不幸的是，睡前故事是你必须付费的东西。但我有一些孩子在睡觉前很难放松，他们听这些故事。有一个故事中男人的声音是这样的，我的意思是，他一开始说话你几乎就想睡着，当然这是一种使用方法，另一种方法不是在睡觉时，而是让他们真正学习如何放松和如何减压，我的建议是上手机，看看不同的。我脑子里有一个我经常推荐的名单，Insight Timer是一个非常好的。
Budify is another one. And again, the comm is excellent. And there's also CBT tools for youth that has a lot of tools on there. And so the idea is to take action. So the specifics of it are not as important as the practice of it in the beginning. So the goal in the beginning is to say, hey, we need to carve out some time to unwind where we're not thinking, where we're suspending our thinking, we're getting. into our bodies, we're learning how
Budify是另一个。再次强调，comm是非常优秀的。这里还有面向青少年的CBT工具，上面有很多工具。所以这个想法是采取行动。因此，刚开始时，具体的细节并不如练习本身重要。所以一开始的目标是说，嘿，我们需要腾出一些时间来放松，我们不用思考，我们暂停思考，我们进入
to do some awareness. I have a family. They watch YouTube videos of people doing yoga for 10, 15 minutes after well, they have this routine where they eat much earlier in the day and then they go like a little bit on a walk and then they come back and they do these
我们的身体，我们正在学习如何做一些觉察。我有一个家庭。他们看YouTube视频，人们做10分钟、15分钟的瑜伽，好在他们有一个习惯，就是在白天更早的时候吃饭，然后去散步一小会儿，然后他们回来做这些
yoga poses. But I think the idea is for parents to make time for it. And then once they're doing it then they can really refine what kinds of things their child likes and benefits from. Well, Dr. Zucker, thank you so much for joining us today. This was really helpful. Thank you so much for having you. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the topics we discussed or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingof psychology.org.
瑜伽姿势。但我认为这个想法是让父母为此留出时间。一旦他们这样做了，他们就可以真正完善他们的孩子喜欢什么并从中受益。好吧，祖克博士，非常感谢你今天加入我们。这真的很有帮助。非常感谢邀请我。谢谢收听。如果您想了解更多关于我们讨论的话题的信息，或者如果您想听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站speakingof psychology.org。
With the American Psychological Association Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过美国心理学协会心理学访谈，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子发表评论。